DEENIUS: You never
know in advance
when you have the
next idea for a song,
or when you have an idea
you don't know if it's
going to make it into the song.
So that's why an
app like Topline
is such an important helper.
We can use it to record and
organize our ideas at anytime
from anywhere.
DOM DRONSKA: We've been
innovating music recording
process ever since the
studio has been built.
Perhaps we're most
known for the Beatles,
but, naturally, we
shouldn't forget
all the other great artists,
starting from Pink Floyd going
to the latest and the greatest.
So for the last few years,
we've been specifically looking
at the music writing process.
And we can see how we change.
And we noticed that
people are coming up
with their ideas,
musical song ideas,
at the worst possible moments.
So we wanted to
develop something
to make that
initial spark easily
captured, to make sure that
they don't lose their ideas.
IZA KIERZEK: Having
all that in mind,
we created a user friendly, very
minimalistic looking IOS app.
Artists can use it to
record ideas and use
stacks to organize them
very cleanly in the app.
DOM DRONSKA: People were
asking for two things.
They're asking for a
version in their country,
and then they were
asking for Android.
There were so many
of those requests
all over our Facebook,
all over our Instagram,
all over our Twitter.
We just had to develop
it very, very quickly.
IZA KIERZEK: And we have
Miquido said that, well, OK,
we can do it.
But it wasn't as
easy as we expected.
While the app
itself looks simple,
it actually has a very
complicated structure inside.
So we had to look into
innovative solutions
to make sure that we can get
top line Android quickly.
After some research,
we found Flutter.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Flutter is
a free and open-source SDK
created by Google.
It features a single
code base, which
allows you to craft native
apps on both IOS and Android
at the same time.
One of its key features
is stateful hot reload.
This allows developers
to make changes
while the app is running in
real time, which speeds up
the troubleshooting
process immensely.
Flutter also has plenty
of customizable widgets
to help you build beautiful
interfaces in minutes.
IZA KIERZEK: And we used
one of those widgets
to create a pretty
neat swipe menu.
Overall, the implementation
of Flutter's SDK and plug-ins
was very, very simple.
Thanks to Flutter, we
were able to finish
developing the Android
version in just 10 weeks
with a small team
consisting only
of three people, one Android
and two front end developers.
DOM DRONSKA: As we wanted
to democratize music making,
it was very important
for us to have
the full versions of the app
available as soon as possible.
So we are super excited
that our app is now
available on both
IOS and Android.
J FRANCIS: Topline has made
making songs so much easier.
It has become a vital part
in our creative process,
and we're looking forward
to making much more songs
with it the future.